[Music]
fingerprints
yep pinka pinka really is a german slang
word for money
it apparently comes from the sound of
coins clinking together
and that's a sound you'll hear a lot in
germany because here
cash is still very much king
[Applause]
nearby countries like the netherlands
and sweden are edging ever closer to
becoming cashless societies
but in germany three-quarters of all
transactions are still made using notes
and coins
on average germans carry around more
than 100 euros in cash
and it's little wonder lots of
restaurants shops and ticket machines
still don't accept card payment here
even though contactless and mobile
payment technology is slowly creeping
into the country
is
the fact is most germans value security
and data privacy over convenience
and that's not particularly surprising
given the country's not so distant
history of state surveillance
despite refusing to step into the 21st
century in terms of payment innovation
there's no denying that germany is a
financial success story
from broken post-war economy via the
vietchasmender or economic miracle
all the way to securing the title of the
largest economy in europe and the fourth
largest in the world
so what's the key to germanic prosperity
someone frugal is known in german as a
spa fox or saving fox
and well you could say that saving fox
is germany's spirit animal
that's not to say the germans are tight
but wow do they love a bargain
[Music]
this is the home of the discount
supermarket after all
while it's generally considered bad form
to discuss how much you earn here
it's positively encouraged to talk about
and compare the prices of goods and
services
i was once on a date with a german and
the conversation took a sudden turn
he wanted to compare the price per kilo
of various vegetables in german and
british supermarkets
hashtag romance but it's not all about
bargain hunting and penny pinching
the germans have a particularly
pragmatic rainy day mentality
don't spend more than you earn always
put a little bit aside
you never know what's around the corner
on average german households save 10
percent of their income
that's more than twice as much as the
average person in the eu or the us
oh and the germans are really wary of
debt if my student debt comes up in
conversation
people start to back away from me slowly
as if they think my financial
recklessness might be catching
it's no coincidence the german word for
debt is also
the german word for guilt that's all
from this week's meet the germans see
you next time
and if you're coming to germany anytime
soon don't forget a pocket full of pink
or pinker
you